[Music]
but on your hazmat suits that's right
we're doing curse comments I'm scared
disclaimer I don't find this reddit
funny at all
it's horrible if I live it's a nervous
reaction please so cancel me let's it's
almost 14 years since this movie was
released and I don't understand how okay
okay not so bad pretty innocent it's a
kids movie you wouldn't like to see a
25-cent oh I mean I would speak for
yourself cake cringe what's black hard
and seven inches long I don't effing
know police I just want to be a top post
my life is slowly falling apart my wife
just left me Claire I still love you I
expect the Ricardo joke unfortunately I
think Claire is the only one that knows
the answer this is so sad Claire left
for Ricardo F's in the chain what movie
would be better if it didn't have a
happy ending Toy Story 3 I say roll
towards the incinerator fade to black
credits with a very sad Randy Newman
singing a down tempo you had a friend in
me oh hey Satan it's a goddamn kids
movie that would have been good am I
crazy
I actually liked that idea oh my I feel
my heart crack little boy invites his
entire kindergarten class to witness his
adoption oh it's nice that's a wholesome
pose how about that let's see it let's
see how you guys ruin it if the kids of
his class are orphaned too then he is
evil
what updates yeah what's it his when she
can build her own toys out of ice her
pee will be freezing cold the cold never
bothered her anyway oh great it gets
worse I once found a Elsa and Anna BDSM
video on P hub and Elsa was putting
balls of ice of anise I'll see if I can
find a link headed people did not want
to live what unbelievable
is there some way to start a foreign
exchange program to trade are rising
looters or Hong Kong freedom fighters so
you're saying you want to try no no all
right we got Logan Paul bruh who the F
is yellow the guy he know Oh what am i
doing this Jesus Christ happy birthday
mom and Dan how they got the same
birthday
they're twins there's a freaking giraffe
loose in Minnesota
Jesus Lamar I love Minnesota just wait
until cops find out giraffes are from
alright can we calm it down a little bit
can we get some nicer ones cops who have
played GTA how do you feel regarding all
the cop killing in the game just pretend
they are okay alright we're moving on
elephant brains react to human the same
way human brains react to puppies they
think we are cute my life has no greater
joy than knowing elephants think I'm
cute now imagine a puppy killing your
entire family in order to sell your
teeth as oh how could you do this can we
do the whole someone instead I want to
go back to the wholesome ready roses are
red I love bread cops shoot at flying
cockroach but accidentally killed
it was auto-aim you are watching pee you
hear no sound even though it's max
last night I was watching bee and I
accidentally pressed Casta TV
and found a Samson TV and started
streaming I don't have what is this I
was try to watch Pokemon I can't read
these I'm not reading that for more
until a tactical nuke oh my god it
didn't used to be this bad on cursed
comments Jake Paul charged with
misdemeanor trespassing after mall
looting the whole of reddit him no don't
even think of that
and Logan Paul will film it that would
be the epic conclusion of the full
brother saga obviously don't do that
I don't incite violence to anyone that
is wrong violence is bad thank you okay
you have your mother's eyes seriously
though how the hell Nicki Minaj sleep on
their side but do you think every time
she turns she make a such a loud clap
that it sends supersonic waves I think
yes
so she wakes herself up while sleeping
girls sounded like my 12th grade
chemistry teacher yo WTF you had mrs.
Richard - I thought you sounded familiar
bro I think we went to the same school I
think why mrs. Richards girls when you
see them in underwear girls when you see
them in bikini the difference is usually
consent I wish I knew that earlier okay
I'm getting nervous when your
secretaries BJ was so good you almost
told your wife Oh Hilary I had a
wonderful day get it Hilary get it if
you snort a person's ashes like cocaine
you gained their knowledge really then
why am I still stupid I'm sorry what you
didn't choose the right people
you got a snorting Stein come on if
wookies have a 400 year lifespan that
Han Solo is basically like Chewbacca
Startalk Han would have lived longer if
Chi we had gotten
nitch true that's actually true I can't
argue with science and facts autistic
artist draws 18-feet picture of New York
after taking 20-minute helicopter ride
over city damn that's insane
see vaccines aren't that bad I have a
lot of problem with this where when
girls would literally blow on a guy
peepee and inflate the test if you know
you know so a funny story
oh god no God don't share it I live
alone have a pull with these in it so
one time I was in the pool I got rowdy
anyway I put my butt up against it and
moan so loud
I swear Antarctica folks is held back
that's not a funny story not a funny
story thanks for the clarification bad
happy 21st birthday to my beautiful
daughter left railing all right let's
see someone ruin it definitely would
smash and there one on the left's not
bad either yeah yeah got it
hilarious it was funny on itself what do
you think sex was like back in medieval
times
what about cavemen times Oh God Bunga
let me smash Oh Bo gobble go ooh what do
you do instead bullying get god dammit
god dammit god dammit scan of a
thousand-year-old Buddha statue revealed
the body of a monk in an inside jesus
winner of hide and seek competition a
thousand nineteen circa last month my
wife stepped on my controller breaking
it today I woke up to this you replace
her with a controller dedication gamer
respect right there
be out of here you break my controller
yeah
god damn it which combo tastes better no
I said no my son got the spider-man
custom he's been wanting forever today I
held him up in various positions and
then Photoshop myself out turned out
pretty good it's pretty cool nails would
have been quicker than photo
okay yeah okay sure Windows XP shut damn
sound pnath tutorial now I make a video
a few days ago saying o overly edgy
jokes are just cringe II Here I am like
I love Stephen Hawking don't get me
wrong I think that's what makes it
funnier I gotta hear it
[Music]
oh god I'm going to hell I'm definitely
going to help never-give-up hundred
that's some good progress respect
I respect the the crunch a man who had a
stroke in 2004 eminently lost the
ability to feel sad oh Jesus that's very
dark I'm always a little happier for
your few seconds after I have a good
stroke - no shame on you shame me and my
younger brother started a breath holding
pull contest he's there for like suno
what would you do if she unplugged your
router in the middle of your game and
smiled like this I'll use the time to
form a strong romantic relationship with
her then I'll eventually lead to
marriage when we eventually grew up
together and we find ourselves in the
hospital on life support I bring up the
time she had unplugged my router then I
unplug her life support and smile like
that a bit remember that one time you
pulled out the router Hey gotcha mate
now we're even
happy birthday Oreo we love to be
creamed as much as you do
let's take this to the DMS so that's
what the mystery flavor was like no no
give me your skin George come on George
mom said it's my turn with the skin yes
I say he's funny after it's funny which
means that I don't find it funny by the
way I didn't make that thing you could
waste it I think like a horrid chance I
don't see an utter on that cow No mind
if I sit here I'm saving that seat for
my boyfriend oh I have a girlfriend it's
that easy
Hera was using chloroform no come on
fringe that was not that funny even the
dog knows this guy should take a
paternity test the dog is so fun
god damn it stop it sometimes I pray for
God to take away my ability to read yeah
I feel like that after watching the
subreddit god I'm not doing this again
okay all right I'm ending it there if
you enjoyed this video hit that like
button gently lots of us to play through
coming up in case it's not out already
join the members and we'll be
live-streaming the rest of it very
excited for that thanks for all the
members appreciate you subscribing leg
reveal at 110 million and I'll see you
guys next time
hey you haven't played two verse
simulator on the beach good pack your
bags and sit down no one wants to see
your face max ten lines anyway download
tuber simulator for the perfect beach
body
[Music]